Let's take a look at how IP address
space is allocated to Internet service providers. At
the top of the hierarchy is an organization
called the Internet Assigned Numbers Authority, or IANA. IANA
has the authority to allocate address space to
what are called regional routing registries. For Africa, the
regional registry is called AFRINIC. For Asia and
Australia, the registry is called APNIC. For North America,
ARIN. For Latin America, it's LACNIC. And for
Europe, it's RIPE. ARIN in turn allocates address space
to individual networks, like Georgia Tech. The address space
across registries is far from even. Now, this graph
is from a journal article that's a little
bit dated now, but it gives you an idea
of how many /8 address allocations have been allocated
to each of the regional registries. So as of
2005, North America had 23/8s allocated to it,
but the entire continent of Africa had only one.
And the recent news is that IANA actually finished
allocating all remaining /8 Internet address blocks, essentially meaning
that we're out of IPv4 address space. So
when you hear that we're out of IPv4 addresses,
it doesn't mean that you can no longer attach
a new device to the Internet. There are various
ways for coping with this pressure on address
space. What that means is that IANA no
longer has any more /8 blocks to give
to these regional registries. Querying an IP address
using Whois and a routing registry, such as
ra.net, will tell you the owner of that
particular prefix. For example, if we run a
Whois query on an IP address at Georgia Tech,
it will tell us that that IP address is from a /16 allocation. That
Georgia Tech is the owner of the prefix and it's associated with this autonomous
system number. The routing registry entry also
gives us some additional information, such as
who to contact if we need to contact the owner of this address space.